allant des coiffeuses je voulais de
coiffeuse
je devais être fait pour ça
c'est formidable vous savez changer le
visage des gens ça peut changer leur vie
on voit arriver des petites jeunes
filles on sent qu'elles sont pas bien
dans leur peau et se sentent femme pour
la première fois elle 60 différentes
elles se trouvent tél
je m'appelle clément et vous c'est
jennifer on dit jennyfer ces anglais et
qu'est ce que vous faites dans ma vie je
suis professeur de philosophie et me
suis coiffeuse
c'est pas un truc d'intello la
philosophie spa de la masturbation
intellectuelle c'est un sport de combat
c'est la meilleure façon de passer c'est
manipuler sais pas ce que ça raconte
mais c'est avec jennifer aniston
franchement je vois pas qui c'est oui
pas qui s'est découvert aniston va pas
mais dans quel monde vous vivez clément
toute façon je suis sûr qu'on a pas les
mêmes goûts pas du tout
à
comment tu expliques un homme qui s'est
tellement de choses c'est plus rien et
qu'on parle de sentiments qu'est ce qui
se passe pourquoi tu dis ça
j'espère juste que tu n'as pas trop
menti